a five-year-old boy who spent four days
trapped in a 32-meter deep well has died
morocco's king has said
footage from the scene in the north of
the country showed workers emerging from
a tunnel dug specifically for the rescue
carrying the child ryan
this evening
like correspondent shingi maori kay is
in the newsroom uh for us now and shingi
not
the outcome anyone wanted
that's right julian the devastatingly
sad ending to a near five-day rescue
operation to try and release that young
boy ryan the five-year-old from the well
in northern morocco today that operation
reached crunch time in those dramatic
pictures we just saw with teams
bulldozing their way to the ground and
then opening up a tunnel to try and take
him from the well
hundreds of people from nearby villages
gathering to come and watch the rescue
effort pandemonium ensuing there and
lots of them hoping that he would be
released from the well alive he was
taken to an ambulance there was a brief
moment of hope as people saw the rescue
operation come to an end but then
confirmation coming just minutes later
from the moroccan king that the young
boy had died and that of course is
already being greeted with lots of
sadness on social media it was a highly
complex and difficult operation which
captured the attention of not just
people in morocco but across the world
but sadly a devastating end to that epic
rescue operation
yes shinki thank you